delicate dim-sum noodles and dipping
sauces staples of Cantonese dining but
for the Chinese it's golden week and
that means a chance to really treat
yourself first I'd like to introduce
Peking duck with Hakkasan special
reserve qiandao caviar here at high-end
Hakkasan in London chefs are working
furiously to cater for Chinese tastes
and Chinese cash close to half a billion
will leave home to make the most of the
national holiday
many flock abroad and they spent 35
percent more on British businesses last
year it's a time to maximize profits
Hakkasan even has a specially designed
menu near the Thai I made these nine
dishes and set the price at 88 pounds 88
pence per person in Chinese culture we
believe it's a lucky number perhaps
equally important service must be
authentic - we have Chinese speaking
staff which managers even receptionist
if make them few this is the second home
and at the end of the meal you get this
a macaroon
but not just any macaroon a golden
macaroon with champagne in it and
popping candy for that fizz
it's pretty much all out extravagance
here